For approximately 80 years, the notion of
what a man should be like has been heavily
influenced by the idea of ‘cool’. The
cast of seductively cool figures includes:
Humphrey Bogart Jean-Paul Belmondo, Marcello Mastroianni,
James Bond, Bob Dylan, Ryan
Gosling and Benedict Cumberbatch The cool
man doesn’t try too hard, you don’t see
them floundering about in a panic – but
they succeed anyway. They are physically confident,
they can scale a mountain or saunter down
a deserted street in the middle of the night;
if they have to kill someone they will do
it neatly with minimal fuss; they don’t
worry, they are self-contained and sure of
themselves; their trousers are always a perfect
fit; they express themselves briefly – but
their words are always to the point; they’re
not meek in the face of authority; but they
don’t crave power themselves: they are independent.
The essential characteristic of the cool man
is an aura of invulnerability, well handled:
without any showing off or bragging. When
the house is on fire, the cool man doesn’t
scream or call the fire brigade; ‘temperature’s
rising, baby’, he quips to his current girlfriend
as she emerges from the shower. Then he casually
puts out the blaze himself. When the waiter
spills a cocktail over him, the cool man doesn’t
get flustered; he removes his jacket and looks
even better in his shirt. When his boss is
being difficult, the cool man smiles ironically:
he can walk away from the job at any moment.
This is what, as a man, one is supposed to
be like. For decades some of the most astute
and creative minds have devoted themselves
to making this notion of masculinity attractive
– it’s been portrayed as enviable, seductive
to women, and well-dressed. And the image
has worked: it’s what you need to be a real
man. And – perhaps daily – this model
of manhood tortures us with the gap between
its ideals – and our reality. THE WARM MAN
But there’s another – more realistic and
more important – vision of what a good man
is like that’s (comparatively) been given
very much less attention and creative encouragement.
This is the very opposite of the cool man,
what we call: the warm man. The warm man does
not put out many fires by himself. He hasn’t
killed anyone either. He is, instead, very
much alive to his own anxiety. He would drop
the gun and would tell you quite candidly
he had done so. What is distinctive, and admirable,
is his relationship to this anxiety. He is
aware of it, honest about it, funny with it
– and yet not overwhelmed by it. The warm
man has a good sense of how demented and fragile
we all are. So he goes out of his way to reassure,
to be forgiving and to be gentle. He has tried
very hard, at times, to get things to work
out better for himself but it frequently hasn’t
worked. The warm man has known many sorrows:
he has done stupid things, he has lost people
he loved, he has made daft decisions. His
weaknesses have made him immensely generous
to others. When the waiter spills the cocktail,
the warm hero laughs (he has spilled a few
himself) and leaves a generous tip if he can.
When he forgets someone’s name (which he
does quite often) the warm hero is ashamed
but frank and says – sincerely – ‘I’m
really sorry, and very embarrassed, but it’s
slipped my mind… forgive me, help me out…’
. When they’ve messed up at work, the warm
person admits it, feels sorry, openly apologises
and explains as best he can what actually
went wrong and how he might be put it right
in future. The essence of the warm man is
vulnerability well-handled; he is conscious
of his flaws and failings but uses this knowledge
to become interestingly humorous and a rich
source of sympathy for the secret troubles
of every life he encounters.
Ideally, one day, it
will be as desirable to be called warm as
it currently is to be labelled ‘cool’;
there will be lists of the 40 warmest men
under 40; boys will come home from school
and complain to their mothers: ‘I can’t
do it, I can’t, I don’t know how to be
warm’; girls at fashionable bars will take
mental notes of where the warm guys are sitting;
and in the secret soul of every man there
will be a quiet, steady yearning to be as
warm as they possibly can.
We love bringing you these films.
If you want to help us to keep bring thoughtful content.
Please consider supporting us by visiting our shop at the link on your screen now.